what's up guys gotta reshoot an intro
that's why it's really dark in here
right now
don't worry the reaction itself will
look a lot better we're gonna watch the
boys season two episode three today make
sure to subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when
our next reaction for the boys is up or
if there's something that just pops up
in your feed that intrigues you from our
channel
friendly reminder youtube only allows
about 10 minutes worth of footage from
the show to be
shown so this is reaction highlights
full length reaction watch alongs will
be over at our patreon page where you
sync up with the time code
speaking of patreon we'd really
appreciate your guys support if you
could become a patron eject today
over there we cover a lot of tv shows
we're at the same tier we have the
option for reaction highlights and watch
alongs included those shows
are supernatural doctor who joseph's our
adventure the promised everland attack
on titan death note my hero academia
code kia's honor hunter one punch man
fullmetal comes brother pilot every card
demonstrator and we also do watch alongs
for a bunch of other shows as well and
lastly i want to give a special thanks
to eric over at nerd chronic who is like
the main editor for the movie trivia
showdown he is for a bunch of reactors
you might
have seen before thank you so much for
cutting this together for us buddy is an
amazing editor
and good friend too good friend too but
more importantly a good a better editor
than a friend
i don't like go check out his podcast
river podcaster
billy joel are the writers big fans of
billy joel
i mean dennis quaid is
my son i have one wish for you i can get
you this role
sorry it's the first step
yeah what's
you don't think it compromises her
allegiances if it comes to that
oh neutralizer she's right behind you
man
it's truly touching
don't condescend him when he's giving
you the answer i told you i knew someone
was right behind him it's just a figure
speech
oh god
we're gonna get demonetized for matching
audio
[Laughter]
they can even tell the sign language
that's how good the algorithm is
you don't know americans i was going to
say don't do that
we will find a way it's advanced
interrogation this should be a reality
show oh god the milk
has swirled around his mouth oh
disgusting oh my god
kieran raisin bran before c
you're teaching our child spinach you're
speaking mexican boy
i want to shoot the whole thing handheld
right very green grassy very grounded i
want to take the audience and literally
put them boom
right there in the action what's the
plan on translucent that's a great
question okay we're gonna take a stunt
man put him in a jumpsuit and just cgm
out and
i'm sorry to interrupt this love fest i
just want to be a part of it
you right all women is either unknowable
hitchcock [ __ ] or michael bay
balls i mean i get that a lifetime of
jerking off to transformers didn't
exactly make you popular with the ladies
but
um well effort would be nice i love her
who is this actress
but i do have two sisters okay hell yeah
man
you that's all you did you go
if this is all true i will get a
strategy together with crisis management
and pr
we're fine for now ashley sir is it true
we're investigating what what's going on
sir i have to tell you something i don't
think we're supposed to know
here we go here we go major breaking
news what's going on superheroes
are not born compounded oh damn
produced and administered by vaught
international
whoa that's a turn of events
we're going to lose everything i mean
cars
houses bonuses there are more important
things you don't know what you're
talking about starlight yeah my movie
deal
poor people people who grew up with
money oh
good point bro good point oh damn
i did not grow up with money so if
anyone wants to pay me
anxiety in the affected children
especially
oh even he's sad
[Music]
superheroes
here
you can't even give me this can you i'll
buy you a nice big family-sized bottle
of top
shelf lube and tickle your boobs
stop and even then i won't just won't do
it
[ __ ] can go sideways just like
so all of you keep your [ __ ] eyes on
the ball
yeah he makes a good point he makes a
really good point
yes go [ __ ] yourself hughie [ __ ] you
[ __ ] the [ __ ] out of here with that
smushed face yeah that'd be like if our
government told us that aliens were real
and we just didn't give a [ __ ] about it
babe keep politics out of this political
commentary okay yeah
you ready
um ready for what it's a job
oh no yeah i hope this kids are just
[ __ ] evil by the end of this season
that'd be great
you called me dad
knock him off no just knock him off now
i knew it oh my god
what did you do it's fine it's a 20-foot
drop relax
inhuman [ __ ] monster i need you to
wake up baby
can you hear me i'm right here i don't
think he's reading
he's flying he's breathing i don't think
he's mad
see i told you and i've been bleeding
because he's my son so he he would be
like the
yeah firstborn born superhero yeah what
i did
to you let's give you a son oh
you're craving like a little girl oh you
creep
oh go with me now the power's coming out
yeah
oh brad bird yes
you're just like me no i'm not like you
i'm nothing like you i [ __ ] hate you
hey it's okay i'm not angry it's okay
i'm not angry
maybe this is her chance to leave while
we can elena if we do that
you know what'll happen
homelander will be here
not the interrupting am i you know i
have super hearing
right oh [ __ ]
life huh
should you say [ __ ] right now
what [ __ ] well you haven't heard
where have you been no he hasn't heard
it god
uh oh you know oh y'all look like
terrible criminals now
i was just wondering have you ever seen
the music video for that billy joel song
you're only human and now i i feel like
i'm i'm that kid
and thank god i found my second win
because it's it's you
second win um
okay
oh god we're all feeling like hatred
right now
right now catching this super terrorist
is the villain
super development
sure whatever it must be
he doesn't care about us we're not his
partners we're his product
so who gives a [ __ ] if thought burns the
[ __ ] ground you should think before
you
say something you don't mean really
should i we
are not bought world still needs
superheroes and that
family that's what we are so let's get
out there
and do what it is we do
does that oh
oh they hit a whale didn't they they hit
a [ __ ] whale
she can't handle animal deaths heads up
wow and they're gonna need him to
oh oh no oh this is not your episode
baby
oh my oh
there's the whale wow
[Music]
that's a joke
oh they're gonna crash into it they're
going to crash into it you don't want to
watch this baby
i'm not watching oh god coming in
oh my god oh
[Applause]
wow did they do it oh yeah they've done
it they crash right
i don't think you should maybe you
should just
leave maybe you should get in the car go
home um
you know what can you guys go ahead
here's your canary you let your canary
die
how you gonna know when you're going too
far oh
we want a load of bollocks
just like that reenactment that was good
he said
hey what happened he killed her they
[ __ ] killed her man what i just
decided to help out you know i got some
intel
sorry i was just like i tried to stop my
credit card
i'm going to do everything in my power
to renew my light
not just for you but for all the female
people that i've offended
[Music]
you got my message yep that's what it
was yeah
[Music]
she had to man we'll be talking about
messages and [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] he heard it oh until it hurt
i'd like you to do something for me okay
oh no
oh no hands in the air
like you just don't care
william what a surprise
[Laughter]
you know i had a great breakfast with
your wife this morning oh
eat this [ __ ]
oh
oh they're back oh thank god we could go
back to loving huey
[Laughter]
hey guys
[Music]
no don't do it [ __ ] don't do it
oh [ __ ]
come on kimmy ko yes thank you
thank you oh my god oh it's like
terminator 2.
[Music]
oh my god she is murdering so many
people
wow
oh they're gonna get all the blame
oh hell no you better not kill her off i
swear to god no
don't you dare
oh okay
oh my
[Music]
i hate her so much
[Applause]
there she is something seems messed up
but i did not expect
that you snooze you lose gramps
oh god
oh oh taking the number one spot team
homelander
[Laughter]
all right cool i got this conflicted
shadow going on
the most dramatic review i'm at a
crossroads what do i do before the
finale
clintus with lighting here so you guys
get today from me it's 110 degrees guys
so we're not going to talk for too long
okay
but things are popping off yeah it's
like the the setup complete you could
really feel the pulse of the show
really coming into play in this
particular episode you know i love that
turn of events of how the compound v
gets exposed to the world huh that's the
creation of the superheroes
all right we got a victory and then you
know butcher even though everyone's like
boosh you're being a dick i'm like
butcher's always a dick what's your
guy's problems
to butcher that's his thing he's a dick
and that's why we like him so we like
him because he's a dick but he gets the
job done and he knows more than most
people
so right away like he says things are
changing a snap and then sure enough
with the brother breaking now taking
down the helicopter
deep and the the whole thing with the
whale but all that with the reveal of
storm front all right that's like
i imagine that's the main thing on
everyone's mind they just slowly
not slowly but bit by bit started
letting you go
oh she's she's messed up what she just
murdered that family did
oh my god oh my god oh my god she just
tortured that guy's wrist she likes to
watch them die
she's racist it just kept going up
we've seen evil and corruptedness but
what pure
racism have they done that yet i mean
hollander seems at least like a tolerant
culture
yeah oh my god i went from wow i really
like this new character too oh my god i
hate her kill her as horrible fiery
passion i mean yeah in the last episode
i'm forgetting exactly where kimiko is
from her actual country they're having
the discussion of like here's what the
americans are like
then you just kind of it's like a just
this big slap in the face
to the brother right there to die that
way and then have a racist for mark
throwing his way
at that moment too after he warned her
yeah what the superheroes were and why
he
wanted to be on the other side yeah this
is how they are when they come out and
do their foreign policy and this is what
they don't show you guys
yeah brutal and then of course like the
whole thing with vod
you know just completely backpedaling
and acting like they didn't know and
blame it on a dead woman you know i
think it was kind of expected for that
to happen because
all of season one was about oh if we get
compound b out the world will change
but realistically that's not what
we'll see i mean there's so much set up
right now of craziness that could go on
it's it's like as much as their stocks
are plummeting and the world is like
what the hell the superheroes are made i
don't know where this show is gonna go
but i imagine a scenario where there's
gonna be some people are like we gotta
get our hands on some compound v then if
we can you know
have powers ourselves right or you'll
see another
typical entity coming up with their own
they could sell this for a lot of money
exactly they could they could find a way
to get even more
corporate greedy evil and just find a
way to profit more by oh we could now
sell compound b
yeah and now that it's not a secret you
know after a certain period of time then
they're going to have to release the
details so that their
competition is
i mean between the three episodes this
is definitely the most like exciting
and most pulse-pounding of them all the
[ __ ] deep dude
he's just the saddest character and yeah
and and then bringing that
whole thing back with homelander like
telling him to put his skills
yeah oh disgusting it is funny because
you know you're not wrong we've talked
it's true
objectively we've talked about you know
the
grayness of of you know the deep as a
character because obviously we meet him
in this really shitty way but now i'm
sitting here going is he gonna
like rift away from the seven because of
this like is his self-empowerment
journey going to put him
in some kind of weird rogue position
where now we're gonna begrudgingly work
with him or something like that because
he knows there's secrets no i think he's
going to go to the cult
like i think this story for him is how
he goes into the cult
thing how he gets preyed upon just
because he has such little self-esteem
beyond that it's like i'm happy that
huey and butch are getting along again
and it feels like they
they got there in a natural way a way
that felt earned
because yeah it's one of those things
with huey where
i always get where hughes come from for
the most part i do but i think i'm
always gonna be
um siding with butcher no matter what
because because
it's like i like huey but i love
butchers there's a main difference there
and part of huey's worth as a character
is being there to be like
well you know we got to think about
other stuff too yeah like he's got to be
a bit of a foil which isn't as fun
because this compound v exposure as much
as they were praising huey
in the beginning of it the fact that it
happened on episode three
means there's going to be some major
repercussions to what goes
on here you're even setting up this
thing with like the seven
disbanding from vaught in some fashion
too like with homelander taking a stan
like just
putting down the main guy in charge in
front
of the other superheroes which is a
great scene by the way
um plenty of great scenes in this only
makes me think that stormfront
is placed there specifically by the head
guy
to kind of keep them in line or to be
protection against homeland yeah
but like homelanders invincible right
yeah can he be killed
i don't think he can yeah i bet that'll
become a big driving force yeah
is there is there an anti-compound v but
i mean as much as there's a bit of a
rivalry thing happening between
stormfront and uh homelanders at least
on homelanders and
yeah now we're all rooting for homeland
i mean
they're gonna like team up in some way i
i don't know
i'm thinking there's gonna be some type
of partnership
with them at first but then homelanders
are going to turn and kill her
this town is big enough i think he's too
competitive to team up with her you
don't think he's going to like feign
partnership no i think she is
threatening and it hinted that at the
end of this episode
how displeased he looked with her
standing up she is a threat
to his leadership position i think he'll
feign being nice to her but i don't
think there'll be a team up
and i don't think she would team up with
him at this point i think they'll have
sex
on it now it might as well we'll see
there were so many just great little
moments in here throughout when butcher
and homelander caught eye to eye his
taunting oh freaking
homelander with that i forgot it's in
this episode where a homelander pushes
his kid off the roof oh yeah
oh god and that like i love how that
whole thing went down too because you
know the kid
proved like he proves to the kid that
he's telling the truth and yet even
still the kid wants
nothing to do with him it is feeling
like the better version of breitbart
it really isn't it made me go i don't
know if we'll see the kid you know
necessarily you know become a huge
main character by the next episode or
something but i can definitely see there
being a lot for him to do down the line
as long as that kid's a good actor and
age as well you get him threatening
queen maeve too which we called last
episode i was like why the [ __ ] are you
saying anything clearly elena's gonna
die
yeah none of you can have phones yeah
sure enough
like why does nobody look around yeah i
know it's
two times in this episode two times has
happened
yeah you know this dude can hear from
anyway i know eric kripke wrote this
episode yeah it must be
one of his tropes then that he just
constantly uses he wasn't expecting the
brother to get killed off
so soon but but they're using it as a
driving force for uh kimiko though well
it seemed like like the most uh bummed
but the most sensible way to alleviate
the problem of us turning him over
as a bargaining chip and now there's
even more motivation yeah for kimiko to
hone in to her own power f some s-u yes
i mean and what's gonna happen with
starlight because she clearly didn't
want to kill him
we don't know if she would have followed
her on that like i don't think she was i
don't want to
start like she wouldn't do that she
can't also attack homelander because
she's kind of invincible
she's kind of caught in between this
rock and hard place we don't know how
she would have gotten out of that
because butchers
i feel like she would have let herself
be killed yeah i think she would have
sacrificed her i mean they were
she got to the part of her the main the
biggest part of her goal which was to
expose vaughn
and that level of exposure is done so i
feel like she's the kind of character
who would be willing to sacrifice
herself
well and because she knows that she has
you know the power that he
obviously does not so like in that
situation i think just that instinct
alone of
well i gotta protect this guy because
what else you know yeah
yeah you know is that really see then
the thing is is that protecting if she
dies
he really loses everything within the
seven
so i'm like sure i don't know and then
black nour was really sad
i love that character so much he's like
this
he's the only one who also has a little
compassion yeah he's so affected by it
the boys are back in town all grizzled
and bloodied up
because this felt the most focused to me
because a lot i've admittedly i've found
most of my interest to be with the
superheroes in the last few episodes
and this was easily the most naturally
intrigued i
was for the title characters the boys
themselves
this feels like yeah the real beginning
of the adventure for them because the
first two episodes almost
felt like transitioning out of the first
season still to me yeah so yeah this
really feels like now all the pieces are
in place and now we're going to catapult
forward on this
compound v exposed the whole thing with
the sun the boys our stormfront
storm fraud as a villain and what's
gonna happen with starlight
all all these new puzzle pieces are set
in place now he's gotta wait
for was it they come out every friday or
something yeah
homelander did look better he didn't
look as exhausted this episode did you
guys notice
his relationship with the sun's getting
better yeah you know really connecting
you know those pancakes you know how it
goes all right guys well
leave your thoughts down below make sure
to subscribe and click that notification
bell we gotta call this video before
we start before we just burst into
flames over here all right
and uh patron of the day shout out
erica tuesday erica look all three of us
are together
it's been a while since the three of us
were with you
making the four
shut the [ __ ] up john john we know erica
better than you
so please let us do the talking i'll
leave the show is this
guy's problem rude rude what were you
gonna say john
i was gonna make a hilarious joke about
how we're not in your hot tub but it's
just as hot as that
[Laughter]
well you would know if that erica would
love that kind of joke well
yeah i mean you know you could get in
the hot tub too we could all get in the
hot tub and just hang out and enjoy life
because nothing's better than enjoying
life
with erica she brings out the good in
everybody
not you john well no one brings out the
good news
worse than you just now i'm just saying
clearly i'm sorry for
america erica thank you for all the
birthday presents and thank you for
being
you i mean we actually know you so do we
need to make this special
no she got you a birthday present yeah
she wasn't she was in his discord video
and she also contributed in the stream
labs you know
that's a birthday present mm-hmm
that she swear well yeah yeah john's
doing
a killer job today in your chat
you know i just wanted to derail the
whole thing my goal was to get in here
take all the structure
throw you off your grooves so thank you
erica this is your shout out you dear
[Music]
people